alors que te souviens-tu de tes
parents - accidents de voiture j'avais 14 ans tu as
commencé à avoir des problèmes de discipline
expulsé de trois internats
après ça parlons de ce jour sur
la plage Trina je t'aime tellement
ce qui s'est passé tu as tout abandonné
après ça  c'est pas toi Mitch
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non pas tout ce que tu penses que tu vas
tuer mes enfants effacer toute sa cellule
tes histoires toi j'aime ton agenda je
sais exactement quoi faire de toi
[Musique]
alors de quoi ai-je besoin  pour connaître ce gars
, c'est un meilleur guerrier que j'aie jamais connu, est-
ce que quelqu'un tue cette viande
ou ces terroristes que vous pensez qui
vous qualifie pour mon processus de sélection, je suppose que
vous et moi allons main dans la main, vous pouvez
probablement comprendre à l'intérieur de  20 secondes
avec un J'ai ce qu'il faut pour faire
quelques processus de sélection alors tu dis me tuer
si c'est comme un coup de ciment ici
comme ça Je serai dans le film
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu penses que nous faisons ici Joe les
gens ont besoin  être tué
[ __ ] tu es un g  hôte tu n'existes pas
[Musique]
la plus grande chose que tu n'es pas prêt
Hiroki
[Musique]
toi